Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number 219
to David P. Speaking of cancel culture,
here's Peter from China saying I am a counselor.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. This is Peter from China.
Yeah. On your recent show, you once again said
that cancel culture was something that didn't
really exist and we should, quote, push back
against the concept of cancel culture, end quote.
So, David, a few months ago, when you
were encouraging your audience to call
their cable provider and complain about Fox
News being among the channel's providers,
what would you call that if not cancel culture?
Was that just a case of activism going too far?
Speaker 1: No, it was neither. Many people
don't realize that they, if they have a cable
subscription, are sending a few bucks to Fox
News. People who dislike Fox News are funding
Fox News. Many people don't realize Fox, compared
to other networks, is more funded by cable fees,
your cable fees than by advertising relative to
other networks. So I told my audience, If you're
displeased with Fox News, you can choose to make
your voice heard. You don't want your money going
to Fox News. You can call your cable provider.
That's not cancel culture. That's me telling
people if you want there to be consequences to the
things that Fox News is saying and doing. You can
choose to call and tell your cable provider
you don't want to pay for Fox News. This is
exactly the point. This isn't cancel culture. It's
consequences to the actions of people based on the
things they do and say. I don't know how many
times I have to repeat it, but Peter from China
doesn't seem to get it. We have a great bonus show
for you today. We're going to talk about Mypillow
Mike Lindell's RNC Camp chairmanship campaign.
We will talk about lawyers ready to sue on behalf
of three students over that AP black history
class that Ron DeSantis wants to cancel. And 70%
declines in one month of ad spending on Twitter.
What on earth is happening over there? Get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up at.
Unidentified: Joint dot com.